I want to welcome everyone to the 10th
annual Gail any a BPD conference we're
so appreciative to have you here today
we're so appreciative that the
conference has been going on for 10
years I'm going to let Perry Hoffman
speak a little bit to the history of the
conference that she and Seth Axelrod
started together but I think what this
has done for a lot of us has offer an
opportunity for many different people
involved in the treatment process for
BPD to come together and listen to each
other and listen to each other's
experiences and learn from one another
and so I hope by you being here today
that you'll also have that experience
and that we can learn from you and you
can learn from us see I want to start
off today hopefully by thanking the
providers the sponsors of the conference
Yale has provided this wonderful
location for us but they've also
provided a lot of resources okay there
we go so we want to thank any a BPD for
all of their support and for the mission
that they've dedicated to educating and
helping individuals with borderline
personality disorder to the Yale New
Haven psychiatric hospital who's been a
wonderful sponsor through the years to
the Yale stress Center where a treatment
and research come together the Yale
School of Medicine Department of
Psychiatry where this conference is now
based and the support that they've
provided i also want to thank our
co-sponsors clearview treatment and
silver hill and i also want to thank the
many people that have volunteered an
incredible amount of time to bring this
conference together for today the
conference coordinators Suzanne Decker
Francesca Jackie Smith Trish Woodward
our conference staff I also want to
acknowledge you'll notice
at the to the right of the stage that we
have interpreting services both terry
mcauliffe and rachel donahue are from
the Department of rehab services and
they are being provided to us today by
the Yale New Haven hospitals
interpreting services department the
deaf and hard of hearing services so we
thank them very much for the work that
they're doing you'll also see today at
registration and throughout the day that
there have been a number of volunteers
that are listed here that have provided
countless hours to help us get this
conference together so we thank them all
heartily thank you thank you Emily and
thank you Emily and her team who've
really and done an incredible job
running these conferences is a full-time
job and when it's not your full-time
paid job it really is quite a feat to
pull off and I know there are over 300
people coming here today so thank you
for such a fabulous job so as Emily said
this is the 10th year of this conference
and I just want to give you a little
history about it we any a BPD Andy and
I'll tell you a little bit about who we
are in a minute but we started doing our
first conference in 2002 we did it at
Columbia University we had over 450
people there over two days and it was
the first national conference on
borderline personality disorder well
Seth Axelrod who is the person who
usually is the chairperson at this
conference and a co-director stalked me
at the next day ABT convention i think
it was in New Orleans or something and i
truly mean he stalked me until he found
me and he said we want to do one of
these conferences at Yale he said we'll
help you do it whatever you need we'll
make it happen and that was the
beginning of what's now a 10-year
partnership so we're sorry that Seth
can't be here we know he's recovering
and we're very grateful for that and I
just wanted to show you the conference's
that we have done over the past decade
so you can just run down to that we
started in 2005 we talked about very
basic stuff then we went on to current
research and treatment went on to
high-risk adolescents and their families
next was trauma and resiliency
and 2009 problems with substance abuse
210 obesity and eating disorders 211
common and distinguishing aspects of dbt
and MBT 12 was impulsivity aggression
and legal involvement 30 20 13 was
managing related cognitive challenges
and bring us bringing us to today with a
decade of development so we hope we and
we invite you to go on our website where
you can download for free all of these
conferences on video and at your leisure
review what's happened over the past
decade so I just also want to tell you a
little bit about our organization our
name is the national education alliance
for borderline personality disorder we
were started in August twentieth two
thousand and one about three weeks
before 911 when we think back how we
were all so innocent that day working on
the disorder and then the world changed
after three weeks after that but there
were seven of us in the room and we were
family members consumers and one mental
health professional and we spent about
10 hours in that room was actually at
New York Hospital in my office I was
working there then was on a Saturday and
we decided that we needed to do
something that this disorder was not
being recognized by the National
Alliance on Mental Illness and within 10
hours we came up with our name and we
came up with an event to do and that was
the first conference that i just
mentioned that we did at columbia in
2001 we are an all-volunteer
organization those of you that see
people speaking today you'll see the
Costello's later this afternoon none of
us get paid for what we do we do it for
the passion we have for the disorder and
for the improvement of lives of people
impacted by BPD there's a dbt listserv
those of you that are DBT therapists
know that yesterday a question came
across the listserv what is the ladybug
about in for awareness and the ladybug
was because each one of the seven of us
had gone at some points in the hospital
either to the cafeteria to the ladies
room and we each came back and said oh I
saw a ladybug we each saw a lady bug in
a different room in the
hospital so the ladybug was born that
day with us and has stayed with us
forever we tried to take it out of our
logo once and we got such an outcry of
emails that the ladybug is is permanent
now I just want to tell you a little bit
about what we do and the reason I'm
telling you about this is that we are a
resource resource for all of you whether
you're a family member or person in
recovery or professional please do go to
our website and use what's there
everything on that site is for free so
we've hosted about 60 conferences we
have a call in series which is really
incredible it's on Sunday nights it's
from eight to nine p.m. it's each week a
different researcher or clinician we've
had the good fortune of having Charlie
Swenson and Kelly Kerner once a month
doing connecting the dots people sign up
to be on the call just because we need
to know how many people will be there we
send out handouts the week before all of
those call ins are also on our website
it's probably the richest callin series
that you can find on the disorder so we
invite you to use it if you'd like to
sign up to be on the call go to our
website and the directions are there we
also on our website have over 150 audio
and video recordings with our
conferences and Collins we have an
online course that's there it was
designed by Louis joy Kane who you will
hear this afternoon John Gunderson and
brian palmer it's on our site for free
it's on Harvard's medical college site
for cost because you can get CME credits
on it we've done two books one done by
the American Psychiatric Association the
other is a book it's the only social
work textbook on borderline personality
disorder and we've just now saw it
recently signed a contract with new
harbinger press with dr. John Gunderson
where we're going to be publishing an
anthology of stories of recovery we hear
so much about people struggling with the
disorder that we felt it was also time
to share the stories of people who have
who serve as inspiration for other
people the the thing that I'm going to
talk about now for a minute we're
exceptionally excited about it's a think
tank that we hosted last week
at the APA they were 25 of the leading
people who are involved in early
detection on borderline personality
disorder those of you who are in the
field and maybe or those of you who have
relatives with the BP with BPD have been
told that you can't diagnose someone
under 18 and in fact actually the
opposite is true you really need to
diagnose someone under 18 because that's
the way people are going to get better
so there were 25 of us we did a think
tank we stayed in one room for six hours
and came up with some action plans to
make sure that this now be is front and
center for the disorder and not
something that people will not talk
about and lastly is our hallmark which
is our family connections program and
you'll hear much more about that and
it'll come alive to you by to wonderful
leaders the Costello's so thank you for
coming think about Mei Mei as BPD
awareness month they are we have our
wristbands we asked for suggested
donation of five dollars it helps
support what we do when we hope that
you'll wear one throughout the month of
May thank you I'd like to ask dr.
William sledge to join me up here dr.
sledge is the George and Esther gross
professor of psychiatry he's also the
deputy chair for clinical affairs and
he's also the medical director for the
Yale New Haven psychiatric hospital so
dr. sledge please join us on stage Thank
You Emily and thank you dr. Hoffman for
your contributions that you and South
have brought to us and colleagues ladies
and gentlemen all of you those of you
who are family members those of you who
suffers of this illness we welcome you
to this venue we're very proud to be a
part of it I think I may have introduced
the first one maybe the second one I'm
not sure which and but this program has
grown up under our species and we're
extremely proud to be here today it's
good to have such a robust audience of
people this condition needs a robust
audience we
advocates providers people who are
intimately familiar with the
circumstances and who are willing to put
in the time and the effort to learn how
to treat it effectively we're all
intimate acquaintances of borderline
personality disorder and we're all in it
together let me begin by thanking the
sponsors again just to make clear that
we are deeply indebted to them the only
Haven Hospital and the system of Yale
New Haven the Department of Psychiatry
of the medical school or have been with
this sense of beginning of course the
national educational Alliance borderline
personality disorder this is a true
partnership with with you and the yelled
stress center and the clearview
treatment center and of course silver
Hill Hospital all to places that join us
in treating this condition and a special
thanks to Emily fulfilling in for Seth
this is much appreciated for those of
you who may not know emily is a gifted
psychotherapy researcher and it's my
dream that someday we'll be able to
figure out a way that she can work it
yale-new Haven psychiatric hospital I
want to acknowledge you dr. Hoffman for
your steadfast partnership in this
endeavor we wouldn't be here without you
and your work with Seth on this project
has been a true act of love and
effective love over these decade and we
continue and hope it will continue for
past all of our times here as long as
it's needed and I want to make that Seth
would be here today I realized he's not
and but I know he's going to see this
and so I want to make sure that he
understands that we're thinking of him
that we appreciate his leadership and
his part in this in the past and in the
future and his persistence in creating
this program in this opportunity we look
forward to having
you back Seth and take care of yourself
and your recovery and we'll see you soon
you're the man
so I think separate from Seth and Perry
is Seth and Perry together in a sense
it's where it's one of those things
where the sum is more than the elements
individually and so I just want to
acknowledge the importance of your
partnership and how you've worked so
well together over this all this time
and how we've been able to continue to
have this to be such an effective
program and so for that we're deeply in
your debt to both of you the time is
right for us to consider and reflect on
the history and the condition of
borderline personality in its connection
to suicidality and other distress states
this field has been a leadership also in
the development of effective
psychotherapies in a general sort of way
for whatever reason the ability to
conceptualize study implement and
reflect on different approaches has been
a premier aspect of the field of the
development of psychological treatments
at least for borderline personality the
rest of the areas of Psychiatry can look
to you for leadership and how to do this
we have a great body of evidence that
supports the effectiveness of
psychological approaches to borderline
personality and we all need to further
that evidence to develop it to
disseminate it to practice it and to
make sure that we practice it well we
have multiple treatments as I mentioned
with different approaches and I'll have
some evidence of effectiveness some
great evidence the presence of these
different approaches though representing
fundamental differences about how we
view human nature have a common pathway
to success and provide us with a
fleeting glimpse of what are the
effective elements of psychotherapy if
we are careful in how we study them and
compare them and think of them so let me
challenge you all today to keep that in
mind as you hear these different
approaches and as you think about them
and you think about what roles they may
play in your operations in your life
these side by side comparisons make us
wiser and we have to be open to
different approaches particularly those
that we're not familiar with so you all
of you here have signaled your interest
in this task by virtue of you being here
and I challenge you to take it up with
energy and gusto and make it easier for
people like me who manage or try to
manage the system to do a better job so
with that let me thank you for your
advocacy for your presence and let's let
the show begin Emily we get started with
with Suzanne Witter Holt there's a
couple more things I want to say I
realized as everyone was talking that
there there are people that usually are
present here that are not that have not
been spoken about yet but the first
person that is actually here that I want
to mention who's also been a key part of
the Yale any a BPD conference through
the years it's Trish Woodward who has
played such an integral role through the
years and helping us plan this
conference and volunteered so much of
her time so so I wanted to just say
thank you Trish for all your work for
through the years for that
she in fact might still be out at the
front table Hershey upstair yeah there
you are thank you Trish and the other
thing that has been briefly mentioned I
just want to clarify so as you might
notice if you've been at this conference
before I am not usually the face of this
conference up here usually Seth Axelrod
is the person moderating for the day and
as you've heard mentioned he's not here
he is on medical leave right now but I
did just speak to him this morning and
he sends his well wishes and wants to
thank you all for coming and he
absolutely plans on being here next year
playing this role so he looks forward to
seeing all of you back next year